I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi there.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好！嗨。
Okay, are you emotionally prepared because we're about to start breaking down goodbye, Michael? I can't lie to you. I am not ready. I am not ready. I don't think I'm ready either. This is Season 7, Episode 22. It was written by Greg Daniels, directed by Paul Feig.
好了，你们在情感上做好准备了吗？因为我们马上要开始剖析《再见，迈克尔》了？我不能对你们撒谎。我还没准备好。我还没准备好。我想我也没准备好。这是第七季第二集。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，保罗·费格执导。
And you know what, Angie, I thought for this one, no summary. No summary. No summary. No summary, no summary. No summary. No summary needed is Goodbye, Michael. It says it all in the title. Yeah.
你知道吗，安吉，我觉得这一集就不用总结了。不用总结。不用总结。不用总结，不用总结。不用总结。不需要总结，就是《再见，迈克尔》。标题说明了一切。是的。
Listen, we're very excited because we have a very special guest to break down this episode with us. It is writer of this episode, Greg Daniels. Greg was with us in the studio for the whole episode, and he had so many amazing things to say that we decided we needed to make this a two-parter. Yes. Today, we will break down the first part of Goodbye, Michael with Greg Daniels, who, By the way, received Emmy and Writers Guild nominations for outstanding writing in a
听着，我们非常兴奋，因为我们请到了一位非常特别的嘉宾来和我们一起剖析这一集。他就是本集的编剧格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格在整个拍摄过程中一直陪着我们在录音室，他有很多精彩的见解，以至于我们决定把这一期分成上下两集。是的。今天，我们将与格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起剖析《再见，迈克尔》的上半部分，顺便说一句，
comedy series for this episode. So well deserved. Oh yeah. And, maybe even more prestigious, Miles McNutt gave this episode an A. Come on! Yeah, it's true. Well Miles, I agree. Why don't we take a break and when we come back, we'll start breaking down this episode
格雷格凭借这一集获得了艾美奖和美国编剧工会喜剧类剧集最佳编剧提名。实至名归。哦，是的。而且，也许更负盛名的是，迈尔斯·麦克纳特给这一集打了个A。拜托！是的，千真万确。好吧，迈尔斯，我同意。不如我们先休息一下，回来后就开始与
with Greg. We are back and we are with Greg Daniels. Greg is here! Hey! Thanks for having me. Hey! So, let's just hop right in. Greg, this episode was written by you.
格雷格一起剖析这一集。我们回来了，和我们在一起的是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格来了！嘿！谢谢邀请我。嘿！那么，我们直接切入正题吧。格雷格，这一集是由你编剧的。
It was directed by Paul Feig. Can you talk a little bit about how we got Paul back to direct this episode and why it was important to you to have him? Sure. Okay. So, just to set the scene, I was very happy that Paul Lieberstein, who was running the show then, invited me back to write this because this was a big he episode and I had a lot of opinions.
由保罗·费格执导。你能聊聊我们是怎么请回保罗来执导这一集的，以及为什么请他来对你如此重要吗？当然。好吧。所以，先交代一下背景，我非常高兴当时担任剧集运作人的保罗·利伯斯坦邀请我回来写这一集，因为这是一集非常重磅的剧集，我有很多想法。
I really wanted to get into it and so I'll just thank Paul for letting me do that. A lot of other folks would have been like, get rid of that old guy. I can't believe that. Yeah. Yeah. So, all right. Well, anyway, I was very excited to write it and the thing about Paul Feig, which was so great, you know, obviously you all know, but you know, Paul was at that point probably
我真的很想参与其中，所以我要感谢保罗让我这么做。换作其他很多人，可能会说，把那个老家伙赶走。我真不敢相信。是的。是的。所以，好吧。总之，我很高兴能写这一集，而关于保罗·费格，最棒的一点是，你知道的，显然你们都知道，但保罗在那个时候可能是
the most trusted director since he had spent the whole year with everybody in season five and you know, there was a lot of emotional stuff happening with this and I think it made people feel very safe to have Paul there and of course, he's also a brilliant director and you know, you bring out your big guns for a big episode. I do remember when we found out Paul was going to direct it that we were all just like, oh, thank goodness that we knew that he knew the show so well and us so well. I do remember feeling safe with that. Yeah.
最值得信赖的导演，因为他在第五季时和每个人一起度过了整整一年，你知道，这里面有很多情感戏，我觉得有保罗在会让大家觉得很有安全感，当然，他也是一位才华横溢的导演，而且你知道的，拍大结局时你会亮出王牌。我确实记得当我们发现保罗要执导它时，我们都觉得，哦，谢天谢地，因为我们知道他太了解这部剧和我们了。我确实记得为此感到很有安全感。是的。
There were some interesting things, I was rewatching the show and remembering stuff and there was a strategy which I thought was really smart that Paul had of taking the most emotional scenes and putting it at the end of the, you know, of the shoot, figuring that people would be pretty emotional by the time they got there and would overlap well. But I remember how difficult it was to shoot the most emotional scenes because it was getting way too emotional, you know what I mean, and it's like I always find it interesting with actors when they're auditioned because they're really comfortable doing something in front of thousands of people or in front of millions of people on TV and then they get into an audition
有一些有趣的事情，我当时在重温这部剧并回忆一些事情，保罗有一个策略，我觉得非常聪明，就是把最情感化的场景放在（你知道的）拍摄的尾声，他认为大家到了那个时候情绪已经相当饱满，会很自然地流露。但我记得拍摄最情感化的场景有多么困难，因为情绪变得太过了，你知道我的意思吗，而且我觉得演员在试镜时总是很有意思，因为他们在成千上万的人面前或者在电视上几百万人面前表演时会非常自在，然后他们去参加试镜，
and sometimes they get all like seized up, you know, and I think it's because they have actual personal stakes on this, it's not they're not pretending, it's like they want to get a job or whatever. Right. And that's what happened here, it's like everybody had an actual personal relationship with Steve, that was, you know, and it was so hard and I just remember, oh yeah, oh my God, it was hard in the editing room sometimes to not have so much tears. Paul did an interview where he said one of the hardest parts about directing this episode
有时他们会变得全身紧绷，你知道的，我想这是因为他们在这上面有切身的个人利害关系，这不是假装的，这就像他们想要得到一份工作或其他什么。没错。这里发生的就是这样，每个人都和史蒂夫有着真实的个人关系，你知道的，这太难了，我只记得，哦，天哪，有时在剪辑室里很难不留下那么多眼泪。保罗接受采访时曾说，导演这一集最难的部分之一
was that people kept crying. Yeah. Scenes with Steve and he said he had to remind us, okay, you guys, you love Steve Carell, but the workers at Dunder Mifflin don't really like Michael. So you don't care if he leaves, except for Jim, because Jim has a personal connection with him and obviously Dwight, who has affection for Michael, but Paul said, everybody you need to act completely disinterested in this exit. And he said it was really hard, he had to keep telling us.
就是大家一直在哭。是的。和史蒂夫的对手戏，他说他不得不提醒我们：“好了，伙计们，你们很喜欢史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，但邓德米夫林的员工其实并不怎么喜欢迈克尔。所以你们才不在乎他走不走呢，除了吉姆，因为吉姆和他有个人联系，当然还有德怀特，他对迈克尔有感情，但保罗说，每个人都要表现得对这次离职完全不感兴趣。”他说这真的很难，他不得不一直提醒我们。
We had to separate reality. He had to give me a minute, he was like, Angela, do you need to take a minute? Because I kept crying and, you know, I'm just showing Michael photos of me and the senator and the senator's aide Thomas, you know, as we're going like to all these different things, antiquing and rollerblading and stuff. But I kept crying. Well, you were the most unlike your character, probably, of anybody on the show. So you were probably the most out of character at that moment, if you were really upset about
我们必须把现实分清。他不得不给我一分钟时间，他问：“安吉拉，你需要花一分钟缓一下吗？”因为我一直在哭，而且，你知道的，我只是在向迈克尔展示我和参议员以及参议员的助理托马斯的照片，你知道的，当我们一起去所有这些不同的地方时，比如古玩店、轮滑等等。但我一直在哭。好吧，在剧组的所有人中，你大概是最不像你的角色的。所以在那一刻，如果你真的为任何事感到难过的话，你大概是最出戏的。
anything. I'm gonna miss you. And they're like, OK, Angela Martin reigned it in. Well, before we get into the cold open of this episode, I dug into my digital clutter, Craig. You know, I'm a digital hoarder. Trademark. Digital clutter.
我会想念你的。然后他们说：“好了，安吉拉·马丁，收敛一下。”好吧，在我们进入这一集的开场戏之前，我翻找了我的数字杂物，克雷格。你知道的，我是个数字囤积狂。注册商标。数字杂物。
Yeah, exactly. Where's my T-shirt? You should have your own theme song for Angela's digital clutter. I do. We do. Oh my gosh. Do you have it? Oh, shoot.
是的，没错。我的T恤呢？你应该为安吉拉的数字杂物创作一首专属主题曲。我有。我们有。哦，天哪。你有吗？哦，糟了。
Angela's digital clutter. There it is. There it is. So I found it. So I found two really fun things. I always like to see what we were emailing about, like what Jenna and I were talking about the week of an episode. And one I'm going to share now, but the other I'm going to save to the very end of the
安吉拉的数字杂物。就是它。就是它。所以我找到了。我找到了两件非常有趣的事。我总是喜欢看看我们当时在发什么邮件，比如我和珍娜在一集的播出周都在聊些什么。其中一个我今天要分享，但另一个我要留到本集的最后再分享。
episode. So it's real special. So stay with us. Here's the first one. It's called Our Hip Jackets. And yeah, I emailed Jenna and Lee, and I said, look at us in our hip jackets. We had gone to the table read and we had made a real effort, the table read for this episode. And Greg, there are a lot of guests at the table read and your wife, Suzanne, was one
所以它非常特别。请留下来听我们说完。这是第一个。它叫《我们的时髦夹克》。是的，我给珍娜和李发了邮件，我说，看我们穿着时髦的夹克。我们去参加了剧本围读，而且我们为此付出了真正的努力，这一集的剧本围读。格雷格，剧本围读时有很多嘉宾，你的妻子苏珊就是其中之一，她就坐在我们身后。我要给你们看一张照片。当然，你们需要注意我们的时髦夹克。这是在致敬保罗·费格穿夹克的习惯吗？我不知道。我觉得不是。它们看起来像绿色军装夹克。哦，不。
of them and she's sitting behind us. I'm going to show you a picture. And of course, you need to note our hip jackets. Was that a reference to Paul Feig's jacket wearing? I don't know. I don't think so. They look like green army jackets. Oh, no.
那些很棒。是的。看那个。看那个。哦，那是我们的拖车。哦，天哪。我知道。它们是为电视布景准备的架子，或者显得很笨重。
Those are great. Yeah. Look at that. Look at that. Oh, there's our trailer. Oh, my goodness. I know. They're a rack for a TV set or being bulky.
一个巨大无比的电视，我们不得不像这样绕来绕去。所以这是我从数字杂物里找出的第一件物品。我们围读了这一集。你和我穿着时髦的夹克，珍娜，我们对此兴奋不已。我很喜欢。我猜这符合你对它的一切期望。我不记得我当时穿的是什么了。那么让我们进入这个开场戏吧。
A big, giant TV that we had to like scooch around. So that was my first item from my digital clutter. We read this episode. You and I wore hip jackets, Jenna, and we were real excited about it. I love it. I guess it's everything you ever hoped for. I don't remember what I was wearing. So let's get into this cold open.
这一集开场时，迈克尔站在大楼屋顶上，期待着搬去科罗拉多。格雷格，你是这样在剧本中描述这个场景的。你说：“特写，迈克尔身处云雾缭绕的天空中，镜头拉远，原来他坐在屋顶最高处一个空调机组上的折叠椅上。他穿着牛仔靴。”布伦特·福斯特曾做过一次采访，他在采访中分享说，这象征着死亡，意味着迈克尔在天堂，因为这一集有一种葬礼的基调。
This episode opens with Michael on the roof of the building in anticipation of his move to Colorado. Greg, this is how you described this scene in the script. You said, close up, Michael is in the sky surrounded by clouds, reveal he is sitting on a folding chair on top of an air conditioning housing on the highest point of the roof. He is wearing cowboy boots. There was an interview that Brent Forrester did where he shared that this was meant to symbolize death that Michael was in heaven since this episode had the energy of a funeral.
哇。你还记得和编剧们分享过这个吗？当然。其实，我的意思是，我不知道这算不算是一种黑暗的隐喻，但它也可以说是，你去了天堂，这是你在人世间时光的美好结局。他将和霍莉一起去往天堂，去往科罗拉多山顶或其他地方。我会给它赋予更积极一点的色彩，不过……
Wow. Do you remember sharing that with the writers? Sure. Actually, I mean, I don't know if it was so much like dark about it, but it was also, you could say, you go to heaven and it's a beautiful ending to your time on earth. And he's going off with Holly to paradise, to the top of the mountain in Colorado or something. I would put it a little bit more positive spin on it, but...
死亡。葬礼。是的。再见，迈克尔。剧本里有很多，我不知道该怎么称呼，但有很多情感共鸣的元素，能让你进入一种情绪状态。显然，我们做得有点过头了，因为我们不得不把它收回来。是的，诸如此类的小细节只是某种视觉上的提醒，就像
Death. Funeral. Yeah. Goodbye, Michael. There is a lot of, I don't know what the term is, but there's a lot of resonances in the script for different things to get you in an emotional mood. Obviously, we did too much because we had to pull it back. And yeah, little things like that that are just visual reminders of sort of, it's like
一点电视诗意。是的。是的。把他们和云朵放在一起。戴夫·罗杰斯分享说，他喜欢那片美丽湛蓝的天空，但很快，阳光太刺眼了，刺痛了雷恩的眼睛，所以你不得不史蒂夫身后放置了一种白色的类似于挡板的东西。所以在这个场景里，如果你看到了蓝天，那是因为那是雷恩的眼睛开始痛之前拍的。
a little bit of TV poetry. Yeah. Yeah. Put them up with the clouds. Dave Rogers shared that he loved that beautiful blue sky, but pretty quickly, the sun was too bright and rain's eyes, so you had to put a white sort of like shield behind Steve. And so in this scene, if you see blue sky, that's because that's before rain's eyes started hurting.
在那之后，你就会只看到白色。雷恩可真像个小宝宝。他拒绝为这个镜头灼伤自己的眼球。他才不会为了跟史蒂夫说再见而直视太阳呢。干得好。我有史以来第一次抓到了收音毛毯穿帮。什么？这也有它自己的主题曲吗？
And then after that, you're going to just see white. What a baby ring was. He refused to burn his eyeball for this shot. He wouldn't look directly into the sun to say goodbye to Steve. Way to go. I have my first ever sound blanket catch. What? Does that have its own theme song too?
没有。在12秒的时候，屋顶地板上，就在史蒂夫坐着的椅子旁边，有一条蓝色的收音毛毯。天哪。哦，我在开场中最喜欢的台词是德怀特说：“你在哪听说的？当然是XM电台。”这台词太棒了。这让我很兴奋。
No. It's at 12 seconds on the roof floor next to Steve as he sits in the chair is a blue sound blanket. Good Lord. Oh, and my favorite line in the cold open is when Dwight says, where'd you hear that? Obvious XM radio. It's such a great line. It proxies me up.
是的。所以在这一场戏中，德怀特出现了，他给迈克尔提供了一些落基山牡蛎。这可是科罗拉多的特色美食。伙计们，我对落基山牡蛎进行了深入研究。你们准备好了吗？我太准备好了。落基山牡蛎其实就是剥了皮的公牛睾丸，裹上面粉、胡椒和盐后油炸而成的。
Yeah. So in this scene, Dwight appears and he offers Michael some Rocky Mountain oysters. It is a Colorado delicacy. Guys, I did a deep dive on the Rocky Mountain oyster. Are you ready? I am so ready. Rocky Mountain oysters are skinned bowl testicles that are coated in flour, pepper, and salt and then fried.
它们有时在裹面包屑和油炸之前会被砸扁。扁的蛋蛋？扁的蛋蛋。它们有别的名字吗？没有。哦。但在加拿大，它们有不同的名字。好吧。
They are sometimes pounded flat before breading and frying. Flat balls? Flat balls. Do they have a different name? No. Oh. But in Canada, they have different names. Okay.
它们被称为草原牡蛎。听起来比落基山牡蛎要小一些。哦，我觉得你就像一只土拨鼠。哦，就像大草原。哦，是的。或者你是从萨斯喀彻温草原弄来的。我还以为它们会有驼鹿牡蛎之类的东西呢。我觉得它们几乎全都是公牛睾丸。
They're referred to as prairie oysters. That sounds smaller to me than a Rocky Mountain oyster. Oh, I think you're like a prairie dog. Oh, like a giant prairie. Oh, yeah. Or you get them from the prairie to one. I thought they were going to have moose oysters or something like that. I think they're almost exclusively a bowl testicle.
好吧。但在俄克拉荷马州和德克萨斯州狭长地带，它们有时被称为小牛炸肉。它们也被称为牛仔鱼子酱、蒙大拿嫩里脊、撒粉坚果或摇摆牛肉。摇摆牛肉？他们在哪这么叫？到处都是。哦，天哪。我注意到没有人用真正的定义。
Okay. But in Oklahoma and the Texas Panhandle, they are sometimes called calf fries. They've also been called cowboy caviar, Montana tender groins, dusted nuts, or swinging beef. Swinging beef? Where do they call it that? Around. Oh my goodness. Nobody goes with the actual definition, I noticed.
是的。没有人直接叫它们公牛睾丸。它们大多在节日上供应，但在科罗拉多落基山队比赛期间的库尔斯球场也能买到。好吧。它们被认为是一种催情剂。真的吗？嗯——哼。
Yes. No one just calls them bowl testicles. They are mostly served at festivals, but they are available at Coors Field during Colorado Rockies Games. Okay. They're considered an aphrodisiac. Really? Mm-hmm.
是的，没错。吃动物生殖器的历史可以追溯到古罗马。我们来啦，格雷格。我们这是要去哪？等等，我在哪？系好安全带。系好安全带。
Yes, that's right. Now, eating animal genitalia dates back to ancient Rome. Here we go, Greg. Where do we go? Wait, where am I? Buckle in. Buckle in. We went from clean beef to ancient Rome.
我们在这个播客里从干净的牛肉直接跳到了古罗马。是的，早在古罗马，人们就相信，如果你的身体某个器官出了问题，只要吃下动物身上那个器官健康的部分，就能治愈你。所以如果你的肝脏不好，你就可以吃健康的动物肝脏。如果你患有，你知道的，阳痿，你就吃阴茎？我不知道。
It's turning to hardcore history here on this podcast. Yeah. Well, back in ancient Rome, it was believed that if you had like a problem with an organ in your body, if you ate the healthy version of that organ from an animal, then it would cure you. So if you had a bad liver, you could eat a healthy animal liver. If you were having, you know, impotence, you ate a penis? I don't know.
也许那时候你就得吃蛋蛋了。我都不知道我是不是该坐在这儿。但迈克尔紧接着确实说过他想在口袋里塞根萨拉米香肠。所以也许……看，这完全符合正在发生的事情。我听到你试图引导我们继续前行了，格雷格，但我决心把我在whatscookingamerica.com上找到的这个食谱告诉你。所以这难道不应该放在网站上吗？
Maybe that's when you eat the balls. I don't even know if I should be here. But Michael does say that he wants to put a salami in his pocket right afterwards. So maybe... See, this is all in line with what's happening. I hear you trying to move us along here, Greg, but I am determined to tell you this recipe that I found on whatscookingamerica.com. So shouldn't that be on like the website?
所以如果你真的感兴趣的话，就可以直接去网站上获取全部内容。我想让大家掌握一些在家制作落基山牡蛎的诀窍。好的。第一点。首先，你在哪能买到食材？这是一个好问题。我不知道你在哪能买到睾丸。
So you just sort of throw it to the website if you're, for people who are really interested, then you can get the whole thing. I want people to have some of these tips for making Rocky Mountain Oysters at home. Okay. Number one. Where do you get the ingredients, first of all? That's a good one. I don't know where you get the testicles.
你去找你的卖牛人。是的。不过，这是建议。第一个诀窍，你要先把睾丸冷冻起来，因为这样在它们解冻时你可以更容易地把皮剥掉。太难受了。整个讨论都要把我折磨死了。第二点，用啤酒腌制两个小时。
You go to your bull guy. Yeah. Well, it is suggested. Number one tip, you're going to want to freeze the testicles first because then you can more easily peel the skin off while they're thawing. Very uncomfortable. This whole discussion is killing me. Number two, marinate them in beer for two hours.
然后煮熟，趁热配上辣椒酱食用。以防你好奇，一个生公牛睾丸含有大约26克蛋白质，脂肪极少，而且富含锌。所以它们对你非常有益。非常有益。没错。好吧，我觉得这里面好笑的笑话之一就是我们其实并没有花太多笔墨。
And then after you cook them up, serve them warm with a hot pepper sauce. And in case you were curious, a single raw bull testicle contains about 26 grams of protein, very little fat, and they are rich in zinc. So they're very good for you. Very good for you. Right. Well, I thought one of the funny jokes in this was that we didn't really put a lot of weight on.
我希望大家注意到了。就是德怀特一边回答问题一边大嚼特嚼。是的。我也注意到了。我看了他吃的东西，对我来说看起来像鸡肉。鸡块？看起来像个巨大的鸡块。我觉得真正的落基山牡蛎看起来确实像鸡肉。
I hope people caught it. It was just quite munching away on them as he's giving his answers. Yes. I did notice. It looked at what he was eating, and it looked like chicken to me. A chicken nugget? It looked like a giant chicken nugget. I think the actual Rocky Mountain oysters do look like chicken.
我无法想象菲尔·谢伊给雷恩炸了些落基山牡蛎。他非常投入。他做事非常彻底。我们可能永远不会知道了。我没有去查证这个。雷恩看起来就像是个摄入了大量蛋白质和锌的人。他确实是。他很健康。
I can't imagine that Phil Shea fried up some Rocky Mountain oysters for Rain. He was very into. He was very thorough. We may never know. I didn't check into that. Rain looks like a guy who's had a lot of protein and zinc. He does. It's very healthy.
他也会吃的。他会吃的。雷恩很喜欢在戏里吃东西。他太喜欢了。每当有机会狼吞虎咽地吃点东西时，我确信他一定高兴坏了，终于能这么做了。作为演员，你们有没有听说过对那种喜欢在场景里嚼苹果的演员的某种批评？
He would eat it, too. He would eat it. Rain loved to eat food and scenes. He loved it. Whenever he had a chance to just completely chow down on something, I'm sure he was so tickled that he got to do that. As actors, have you guys ever heard the sort of criticism of actors that like to munch an apple during the scene?
没有。对吃苹果有什么批评？哦。好吧，我不知道这是否仅仅针对苹果？不是的。这只是演员用来——布拉德·皮特一直在这么做。他真的吗？
No. What is the criticism of eating an apple? Oh. Well, I don't know if it's just a specific to an apple? No. It's just like a little bit of a crutch for an actor to be able to- Brad Pitt does it all the time. Does he really?
是的。他在电影里吃苹果。老兄，去看《十一罗汉》的续集《十二罗汉》。他总是在吃东西。是的。这就像是一种在台词间隙显得非常随意的表现方式，你一边大嚼特嚼一边说话之类的。哦。
Yes. He eats apples in movies. Dude, watch the Ocean's 12 movies. He's always eating something. Yeah. It's like a way to appear very casual as you're giving your lines, you're munching away and stuff. Oh.
安吉拉刚刚把布拉德·皮特推下了车（意指无辜中枪）。我确实为他准备了食品杂货。他当着演员的面吃东西，我当时就在想——我不知道这算不算坏事。这只是一种习惯。我最喜欢的所有《教父》电影和《好肥佬》电影的桥段之一，就是人们吃东西的戏份实在太多了。《黑道家族》的人一直在吃。
Angela just threw Brad Pitt under the bus. I did make his groceries. He eats in front of actors eating and I just was thinking- I don't know if it's bad. It's just a thing. One of my favorite parts of all of the Godfather movies and Goodfellas movies is how much people eat. The Sopranos eat all the time.
他们总是在吃。是的。《黑道家族》。当然。他们的剧组餐饮非常好。好了，现在我们来到迈克尔的办公室，德安杰洛非常想要迈克尔的一个玩具。他想要那个像邓德米夫林纸品运输车的小型18轮大卡车。迈克尔明显很不高兴，他说：“行吧，拿走我最喜欢的卡车。”
They're always eating. Yeah. The Sopranos. Sure. They have very good catering. Well, now we're in Michael's office and D'Angelo really wants one of Michael's toys. He wants the little 18-wheeler Dunder Mifflin-like paper delivery truck. Michael is clearly annoyed and he says, sure, take my favorite truck.
德安杰洛说：“你知道吗？我给你留点空间。我要去休息室待着。”然后他有一段直面镜头独白，说：“呃，行尸走肉。”格雷格，我必须知道这段独白有没有备选的糖果袋笑话（candy bag alt）。格雷格刚刚在外面告诉我了一件事，珍娜，你没听到，我迫不及待想让他告诉你了。你能告诉我们你想出来的——
D'Angelo says, you know what? I'm going to give you space. I'm going to post up in the break room. And then he has a talking head where he says, ugh, dead man walking. And Greg, I had to know if there was a candy bag alt for this talking head. And Greg just told me something outside, Jenna, that you didn't hear and I can't wait for him to tell you. Will you tell us that you came up with-
哦，好吧，“糖果袋”（candy bag）是我的术语。这是他自己编的！你发明了“糖果袋”这个词？是的，是的，他确实发明了。我当时只是想让剧组觉得他们得拍额外的素材这件事听起来既有趣又让人兴奋，以防我们决定不下来到底该用哪句台词。所以，是的。好吧，这是我绝对最喜欢的事情之一，我以前不知道这个词是你发明的，
Oh, well, candy bag is my term. He made it up! You made up candy bag? Yes, yes, he did. I was trying to make it sound fun and exciting to the crew that they have to shoot extra material if we couldn't decide what the lines should be. So yeah. Well, it's one of my absolute favorite things and I didn't know you made up that term and
这让我太开心了。而且这段德安杰洛的直面镜头独白确实有糖果袋备选台词。我要给你们读三个我最喜欢的。呸，看在上帝的份上，专业点吧。分享你的玩具。这挺好。我喜欢这个。下一个。
it makes me so happy. And there were candy bag alts for this D'Angelo talking head. I'm going to read you three of my favorites. Blech, be professional for God's sake. Share your toys. That's good. I like that. Next one.
我来这儿三周了，他根本没碰过这辆卡车；最后，我其实根本不想要这辆卡车。我想要它只是因为他有。我是个直升机迷。我喜欢直升机。我其实觉得这些都比我们最终采用的要好。我最喜欢的是：“我来这儿三周了。他甚至都没碰过这辆卡车。”
I've been here three weeks and he hasn't touched the truck and lastly, I don't even want the truck. I just want it because he has it. I'm a helicopter guy. I like helicopters. I kind of like them all better than what we use. My favorite is I've been here three weeks. He hasn't even touched the truck.
是的。你知道有趣的是什么吗？我当时在检查这个，这也是我真正想加入的原因之一，我对此感到非常自豪。这是一个剧本。而且，你知道的，这是一部获得艾美奖提名的剧本，我觉得我当时可以说是火力全开。剧本里有很多地方都巧妙地穿插了一些小情报，为所有这些不同的故事线做铺垫。
Yeah. Well, you know what's interesting is this, I was looking over this and this was, you know, one of the reasons I really wanted to come in, I was very proud of this. It was a script. And, you know, it was an Emmy nominated script and I feel like I was sort of, you know, running on all cylinders at this point. And there's a lot of times in the script where there's little bits of information that are sort of snuck in that are setting up all these different storylines.
我敢肯定，我们选择“行尸走肉”的原因是它自然衔接了迈克尔接下来的那段直面镜头独白，他在里面说：“我不难过，我明天才走，明天我才会崩溃。”这就为整集关于他到底什么时候走的悬念做了铺垫，这是史蒂夫的主意，这是一种绝妙的方式，掩盖了许多情绪化的东西。所以大家不必像面对他最后一天那样直接跟他说话。他们只是在努力……度过普通的一天。但他知道今天是他的最后一天。
And I'm sure the reason why we picked Dead Man Walking was because it led into Michael's next talking head where he says, I'm not sad, I don't have to leave till tomorrow and tomorrow I'll be a wreck. And that is setting up this whole notion of when is he actually leaving, which is Steve's idea and it's like this wonderful way to disguise a lot of the emotional stuff. So the people aren't having to talk to him directly as if it's his last day. They're just trying to, you know, get through a normal day. But he knows it's his last day.
所以这大概就是为什么我们选择“行尸走肉”而不是其他那些听起来非常搞笑的备选。不过你说得太对了。而且，我和珍娜在准备这一集时讨论过，格雷格，你在写这一集时是多么体贴入微，因为有太多精彩的时刻都在呼应之前的剧集。如果你带着这种心态去观看，我在看的时候真的会被感动得更多。是的。
So that's probably why we picked Dead Man Walking instead of those other ones, which are sound pretty hilarious. You're so right though. And I, I mean, Jen and I were talking about this as we prep this episode about how thoughtful you were, Greg, in writing this, because there are so many wonderful moments that point back to earlier episodes. And if you watch it with that in mind, I just got so much more emotional watching it. Yeah.
我的意思是，看到那个筹备派对委员会的场景，我太高兴了。看到迈克尔在这一集里对筹备派对委员会的态度与第一集相比有多大不同。以至于我提取了第一次筹备派对和这一次的音频片段。我想我们可以连续听听看。好的，我们来听听。好的，太棒了。
I mean, I was so delighted to see that party planning committee seen. Yeah. To see how differently Michael regarded the party planning committee in this episode compared to the first one. So much so that I pulled audio clips of both the first party planning and this one. And I thought we could listen to them back to back. Yeah, let's do it. Okay, great.
蓝色。黄色。红色。绿色怎么样？我觉得绿色有点符合我们的风格。这些是我的派对策划小宝贝们，她们去年成功办了一场超赞的80年代派对。派对。太糟糕了。
Blue. Yellow. Red. How about green? I think green is kind of hourish. These are my party planning biaches pulled off an amazing 80s party. Party last year. Awful.
所以我一直在想，如果你还没买蛋糕的话，或许可以考虑去巴斯金-罗宾斯买那种冰淇淋蛋糕。它们非常好吃。非常美味。梅雷迪思对乳糖过敏，所以……吃这个的又不止她一个人，对吧？我想大家都喜欢冰淇淋蛋糕。这不是，呃，不仅仅是为了她。
So I was thinking if you haven't already gotten a cake, maybe go in for one of those ice cream cakes from Baskin Robbins. They're very good. Very delicious. Meredith's allergic to dairy, so. She's not the only one that's going to be eating it, right? I think everybody likes ice cream cake. It's not, uh, not just about her.
所以这是她（喜欢）的薄荷巧克力芯片口味。买这个挺好。来点……所以这是第一个，是的。现在是最后一场迈克尔与筹备派对委员会的戏，对吧？纸杯蛋糕怎么样？拜托。纸杯蛋糕有什么不好？
So it is her chocolate chip. Good to get. How about some... So that's the first one, yeah. And now here is the final party planning committee scene with Michael, right? How about cupcakes? Please. What's wrong with cupcakes?
哪儿都不好。它们来了。筹备派对委员会又聚在一起了。好吧，我们都想为你的告别派对做筹划。我们觉得这样会轻松点。我们觉得我们已经决定好冰淇淋了。薄荷巧克力芯片，你的最爱。姆——
Everything. There they are. Party planning committee together again. Well, we all wanted to plan your goodbye party. We thought this would be easier. We thought we decided on the ice cream. Mint chocolate chip, your favorite. Mmm.
是的，这真是个惊喜。你知道吗？也许我们应该买大家都喜欢的冰淇淋。买香草味的吧。我们买香草味的。好的。明天，我希望每个人都过得开心，不要有任何抓马，至于今天，就当作普通的一天。
Yeah, that was a surprise. You know what? Maybe we should get ice cream that everybody will like. Have a vanilla. Let's get vanilla. Okay. Tomorrow, I want everybody to have a good time, no drama, and as for today, just a typical day.
好吗？我们要加配料吗？你喜欢什么，帕姆？什么？你想加什么配料？热豆？听起来不错。加满热软糖。
All right? Should we get toppings? What do you like, Pam? What? What kind of topping would you like? Hot foot? Sounds good. Fudge it up.
我喜欢他们的一点是，筹备派对委员会的动态一点也没变。没有。是的。我们在彼此共事的能力上可以说是一点长进也没有。是的。我喜欢你当时被问到意见时表现出的那种惊讶。是的。
What I love about them is that the dynamic of the party planning committee has not changed. No. No. Yeah. We have grown not at all in our ability to work with one another. Yeah. I love how surprised you were at being asked your opinion. Yeah.
那段演得太好了。什么？有时候这就是那种你会担心这是个陷阱的事情。是的。真的，这对话要走向何方？是的。好吧，我的意思是，这是在那里悄悄塞入一些精彩背景信息的另一个例子，因为他说像，我今天不希望有任何抓马，就当是普通的一天，这就奠定了他
That was such a good read. What? It's one of those things sometimes where you're afraid it's a trap. Yeah. Really, where is this going? Yeah. Well, I mean, there's another example of slipping in some good exposition there because he says like, I don't want any drama today, just a typical day, and that's like sets up his
对这一整集的全部期望，然后，你知道的，这让我们能从一个非常微小的情节点切入进行幕间休息，比如，哦不，我不是明天走，我是今天四点走之类的。是的。是的。我有一个略带讽刺的问题。是的。我觉得迈克尔要是知道自己根本不会出席派对的话，他可能就不会对冰淇淋口味表现得那么上心了。是的。
whole expectation for the episode and then, you know, that lets us have an act break out of a very slender thing of like, oh no, I'm not leaving tomorrow, I'm leaving today at four or whatever. Yeah. Yeah. I have a slightly cynical question. Yeah. I do think Michael would have been more attached to the ice cream flavor if he knew he was
他是因为觉得自己反正也不会去，所以随便你们怎么样，才能表现得这么大方吗？如果我不在吃，我就不用掌控它。是的。完全正确。是的，太搞笑了。
going to be at the party. Yes. Is he able to be so generous because he's like, I'm not even going to be there, so whatever you want. I don't have to control it if I'm not eating it. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah, it's hilarious.
有一定程度的成长，但并没有成长太多。完全正确。好吧，在这场戏之后，迈克尔有一段直面镜头独白，他谈到自己给自己买了一个“世界最佳老板”马克杯，但昨天整个办公室送了他一个“世界最佳老板”邓迪奖杯，于是他把马克杯扔进了垃圾桶，然后把邓迪奖杯放在桌上，这100%呼应了开场镜头。你们是怎么做到的？
A certain amount of growth, but not a ton of growth. Exactly. Right. Well, after this scene, Michael's going to have a talking head where he talks about how he bought himself his world's best boss mug, but yesterday the whole office gave him a world's best boss, Dundee, so he throws his mug in the trash and then he sets his Dundee on the desk and it 100% mirrors that opening shot. How did you guys do that?
太完美了。你根本看不出来。看起来就像是直接复制粘贴进去的。是的。我当时还按下暂停键，看你们是不是在捉弄我们，其实是切到了原版的镜头，但你们并没有。这是一个新镜头。是的。
It's so perfect. You wouldn't even know. It looks like it's like just copy and paste it in. Yeah. I actually paused to see if you tricked us and you actually cut away to the original shot, but you didn't. It's a new shot. Yeah.
这是一个新镜头。是的。好吧，那是我在拍试播集时加入的东西，那个马克杯，他给自己买的那个“世界最佳老板”马克杯，当你拍试播集时，你总是在寻找，有什么事情是你可以做的，能够概括某人的……存在。是的，用一个视觉元素概括其全部心理。我一直觉得那个道具是一个很好的例子，说明一个人
It's a new shot. Yeah. Well, that was something that I added to the pilot was that mug, the fact that he bought himself his world's best boss mug and when you're doing a pilot, you're always looking for like, what is the one thing you can do that will encapsulate somebody's… Existence. Yeah, complete psychology in one visual thing. I always thought that that prop was like a really good example of somebody who had very
对自己的认知非常有限，所以他能超越那个阶段是很好的，而且那集邓迪奖杯，之前的那个拍得很棒，我不记得是在什么时候了，好像就是在写这一集的过程中我意识到，哦，我们为什么不重现那个镜头呢？纪录片形式的小惯例只在重大时刻极其克制地使用。所以在这一集里，我们使出了浑身解数做成了这个，我们当时觉得，太酷了。这就是第一个镜头出现的方式，再次说明，我觉得这具有很强的感彩，因为你会意识到，哦天哪，整部剧播下来我每周都在看那个。
little self-knowledge and so it was good that he outgrew that thing and then it was a great episode that Dundee episode, previous one was great and I can't remember when I think it was just during the writing of it that I realized like, oh, why don't we see that? The use of documentary little conventions was very sparingly doled out for big moments. So like in this one, we pulled out some stops and we did that and we were like, cool. This is how that first shot came in and again, like I think that has a lot of emotional resonance because you realize, oh my God, I've been watching that every week for the whole run of the show.
那是上一集的出处，所以我当时觉得这很酷。但还有别的东西，比如他最后摘下麦克风之类的动作。我觉得摘下麦克风是英版剧集中的一个重大时刻，我想是的。有个时刻是蒂姆在向唐表达心意时摘下了他的麦克风。是的。
That's where it came in the last episode, so like I thought that was cool. But then there's other stuff like when he at the end takes his mic off and stuff like that. I feel like the taking the mic off was a big moment in the English show, I think. It was. There's a moment when Tim takes his microphone off when he's going to tell his feelings to Don. Yeah.
而且我觉得它甚至出现在圣诞特别篇里，如果我没记错的话。所以很显然，那就像是一颗银色子弹，你只能用一次，而我们把它留到了这里。好吧，迈克尔拿出一张员工姓名的名单，你可以在5分32秒时看到这张名单。格雷格，这张名单对你构思这一集起到了塑形作用吗？你当时有这样一个大纲吗？好吧，让我回忆一下这个小故事，因为我以前曾在一家名为
And I think it's even in the Christmas special, if I'm correct. So that was obviously, that's like a silver bullet that you get to use once and we saved it for this. Well, Michael is going to take out a list of employees' names and you can see the list at five minutes and 32 seconds. And Greg, did that list sort of shape the episode for you? Did you have an outline with that? Well, let me just remember this little story because I used to work on a show called the
《威尔顿·诺斯报道》（The Wilton North Report）的节目工作过。柯南和我都在那儿工作过。那是深夜综艺节目中一段短暂而诡异的经历。他们确实有一个很酷的纪录片制作团队，是该节目的一部分。我当时做过的一件事就是带着这个纪录片摄制组去参加一个家伙的退休派对，他从南加州天然气公司（SoCal Gas）退休了。我们只是把它拍下来，试图从这个普通天然气公司员工的退休生活中寻找一些感人或幽默的元素。
Wilton North Report. And Conan and I both worked there. It was a weird brief experience of a late night variety show. And they did have a cool documentary collective that was part of that show. And one thing I did once was take this documentary crew and go to this guy's retirement party who was retiring from the gas company, SoCal Gas. And we just shot it and kind of looked for something that would be touching or humorous about just sort of this average guy retiring from the gas company.
无论如何，那种情绪为我的这个剧本提供了灵感，因为那个家伙正在接受他共事了很长时间的人们的祝酒。他要离开了。他们送了他一些小礼物，你知道的，比如，“给你个高尔夫球，你打高尔夫时可以用”之类的。但这几乎是悲伤的，非常悲伤，因为他们几乎是把他抬上一艘维京战船，点燃大火把他送走，你知道的。就好像，我觉得他以后再也不会见到这群人了，你知道的。
And anyway, the mood of that informs this script for me because that guy was being toasted by people he'd worked with for a really long time. He was leaving. They gave him little gifts, you know, like, here's a golf ball. You can use it on your golf or whatever, you know. But it was almost sad, it was very sad because they were almost packing him on a Viking ship and lighting him on fire and sending him off, you know. It was like, I don't think he was going to see any of these people again, you know.
那种感觉非常苦乐参半。所以，我的脑海里一直回荡着那种情绪。然后当迈克尔拿到名单时，他就要去拜访大家了。是的。所以，关于这份名单，它有点像是这一集的结构，他要一一道别。所以这份名单很好地指明了我们要去的方向。因此，一旦你看到了这份名单，你就会觉得，好吧，我知道这一集将如何
And it was very bittersweet. And so, I mean, I had that mood in the back of my head. And then when Michael got the list, he was going to go in. Yeah. So, the thing about the list was it was kind of like the structure of the episode is he's going to say his goodbyes. And so, the list was a good roadmap for where we were going to go. And so, once you saw the list, you were like, okay, I know how this episode is going to
推进了。我有一种总体上的感觉，他必须划掉名单上的每个人，考虑到他最后面临的最大困境是他还没去找帕姆，你知道的，从视觉上看到名单并看着除了帕姆之外的每个人都被划掉，这将成为我们的结构，你知道的。所以有一份名单真的非常有用。它绝对让我想起了一点《绿野仙踪》。是的，这里面有很多《绿野仙踪》的影子。
go. I have a general feeling that he's going to have to cross off everybody on the list. And considering that the big sort of dilemma that he has at the end is he hasn't gotten to Pam, you know, to visually see the list and see everybody get crossed off except Pam is going to be our structure, you know. So that was very useful to have the list. It definitely reminded me of the Wizard of Oz a little bit. Yeah, there's a lot of Wizard of Oz in this.
是的。所以，这就有点像最后他们见到伟大的奥兹时，他颁发毕业证书和勋章。这就好比菲莉丝很害羞，不敢为自己说话。她得到了咔哒作响的假牙……完全是这样。而且我觉得迈克尔看了《绿野仙踪》，可能在某种程度上把自己看作了奥兹魔法师。
Yeah. So, it's like that final scene when they meet with the great Oz and he's like, you get a diploma and you get a medal. It's like, Phyllis is shy and doesn't, you know, speak up for herself. She gets the clattering teeth and... Yeah. Totally. And I think he watched Wizard of Oz and saw himself as the Wizard of Oz maybe on some
是的。我确实捕捉到一个时刻，我看到了迈克尔真正的成长，因为当斯坦利送给迈克尔那个新奇的台球桌时，斯坦利说：“这上面没有球。”而迈克尔什么也没说。是的。我也注意到了。这话她没说。
level. Yeah. I did catch a moment where I saw some real Michael growth because when he gives Stanley like the novelty pool table, Stanley says, it's got no balls. And Michael doesn't say anything. Yes. I noticed that too. That's what she said.
是的。嗯，还有，我觉得有趣的是，这也是在为这一集中的这条副线做铺垫，斯坦利得到了这个破损的小玩具，然后安迪紧接着得到了10个最大的客户。他说：“我要失去他们了。我要失去他们了。”而迈克尔说：“我相信你。”然后后来他在场景中间大喊：“我刚丢了一个！”
Yeah. Well, also, I think the funny, that's also setting up this subplot in this episode is that Stanley got this little broken toy and then Andy gets the 10 biggest clients right afterwards. And he's like, I'm going to lose them. I'm going to lose them. And Michael's like, I have faith in you. And then later he shouts out in the middle of the scene, I just lost one.
我刚……角铁五金店。是的。迈克尔，我丢了一部分五金店的业务。是的。是的。哦，太棒了。不，我太喜欢那个了。
I just... Corner Hardware. Yeah. I was lost part of Hardware, Michael. Yes. Yeah. Oh, it's so good. No, I loved that.
那真的很……就像，我确信这在剧本创作时会是一个巨大的笑点。我当时想：“让他从（你知道的）房间那一头大喊”。我也很喜欢剧中那些来自迈克尔的支线情节。呃——哼。
That was really... Like, I was confident that was going to be a big laugh in writing it. I was like, have him yell from across the, you know, I also, I loved it on the show when there were stuff coming off Mike. Uh-huh. You know what I mean? It was just felt so real, but you're just like, oh, we're over here and accounting. Oh, no.
你知道我的意思吗？这感觉太真实了，你只会觉得：“哦，我们现在在会计部这边。哦，不。”是的。我只是在开他B线的玩笑。好吧。我觉得我们应该休息一下。等我们回来，继续剖析这一集。喜欢。我们回来了，我们还在会计部。迈克尔送给凯文一幅画，画的是凯文变成了一头正在吃披萨的猪，但随后他把画
Yeah. I'm just joking from his B plot. All right. I think we should take a break. And when we come back, keep breaking down the episode. Like it. We are back and we are still in accounting. Michael presents Kevin with a drawing of Kevin as a pig eating pizza, but then he tears
撕碎了，并说：“别把自己活成一个滑稽符号，凯文。”我想这就是他送给凯文的礼物吧。这是什么？这个教训？好吧，凯文说：“我觉得自己挺好的。我喜欢我现在的样子。”而迈克尔说：“永远不要安于现状。”是的。
up the picture and he says, don't be a caricature, Kevin. That's his gift to Kevin, I guess. Is this what? This lesson? Well, Kevin says, I kind of like good with myself. I like who I am. And Michael says, never settle for who you are. Yeah.
所以这也许是老派的迈克尔在输出一些糟糕的教训。但我的意思是，我一直觉得——凯文在编剧团队里有点像我的一个小宠物，因为我总是试图保持他的三维立体感，你知道我的意思吗？比如，我喜欢他在篮球那一集中擅长打篮球。擅长扑克。是的。他在某些方面很擅长。
So that's maybe more old fashioned Michael giving some bad lessons out. But I mean, I always did, I mean, Kevin was a kind of a pet peeve of mine a little bit with the writing staff because I was always trying to keep him three dimensional, you know what I mean? And like, I love that he was good at basketball and the basketball episode and. Good at poker. Yeah. He's good at certain things.
而且，你知道的，他还有点音乐细胞，你知道的，除了又慢又胖之外，他的角色还有其他方面。我的意思是，这可能是我在通过迈克尔扭曲的视角（试图为凯文做点好事）来重现我经常和编剧团队进行的对话。顺便说一句，菲尔·谢伊真的很给力。这一集里有很多非常搞笑的道具。比如稻草人？
And, you know, he was sort of musical and, you know, like there were other aspects to his character other than slow and fat. I mean, I think this was maybe something where I was enacting a conversation I had with the writing staff a lot through Michael's twisted, you know, vision of his trying to do something nice for Kevin. Phil Shea, by the way, really stepped up. There's a lot of really funny props in this episode. Like the Scarecrow?
是的。我太喜欢那个稻草人了。菲尔做出了多少种不同的稻草人？哦，我觉得就这一种。他拿捏得太到位了。是的。他完全拿捏到位了。我很喜欢和他一起做道具。
Yes. I love the Scarecrow. How many different Scarecrow's did Phil present? Oh, I think it was just this. He nailed it. Yeah. He completely nailed it. I loved doing props with him.
比如，我不记得是哪一集了，里面有一个威伦多夫的维纳斯小雕塑，你知道吗？哦，是的。那种尼安德特人风格的孕妇雕刻，莫斯或德怀特在农场里好像也有一个。是的。我喜欢那种你看了会觉得：“好吧，我勉强能承认那是艺术，所以它一定是被允许出现在屏幕上的。”
Like there's, I can't remember which episode, but there's like a little Venus of Willendorf statute, you know? Oh, yes. That sort of like Neanderthal pregnant carving that I think Moe's has or Dwight has or something in his farm. Yeah. I love like, like things where you're like, well, yeah, I've sort of, I can agree that that is art and so it must be allowed on screen.
但它又同时那么诡异、充满情色意味且奇怪。我这周去贝尚美（Bed Bath and Beyond）购物，突然听到安吉拉的声音，我一转身发现是菲尔·谢伊，他手里正拿着三种不同织法的灰色毯子。我说——在进行选择的头脑风暴吗？没有。正是。选哪条毯子？
But it's also like so weird and, you know, sexualized and strange. I was at Bed Bath and Beyond this week and all of a sudden I hear Angela and I turn around and it's Phil Shea and he has three different types of woven gray blankets that he's holding. And I was like- Steaming of a choice? No. Exactly. Which blanket?
我知道。我当时想：“菲尔，你在干嘛？”他说：“我在为《美国汽车工人》采购灰色毯子。”哦，原来如此。是的。然后我们最后聊了一会儿，见到他真是太棒了。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州威斯敏斯特的贝茜·Y的粉丝提问，她说：“自从播客开播以来，我一直等着想问一个关于这一集的问题。”
I know. I was like, Phil, what are you doing? He's like, I'm shopping for gray blankets for American Otto. Oh, that makes sense. Yeah. And then we ended up chatting for a bit and it was so great to see him. We got a fan question from Betsy Y in Westminster, Colorado, who said, I have been waiting since the beginning of the podcast to ask a question about this episode.
我知道。当时我想，菲尔，你在干什么？他说，我在为“美国奥托”买灰色毯子。哦，这就说得通了。是的。然后我们聊了一会儿，见到他真是太好了。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州威斯敏斯特的贝茜·Y的一个粉丝提问，她说：“我从播客开播以来就一直在等一个关于这一集的问题。”
Oh, wow. My favorite scene from the entire show is when Michael gives Oscar the scarecrow and then Michael's talking head afterwards where he is laughing. I need to know everything about this scene. How did Oscar not laugh? Was Steve laughing for real? Was this improvised? Well, I went to the script.
哦，哇。整部剧里我最喜欢的场景就是迈克尔送给奥斯卡那个稻草人，然后接着是迈克尔在事后采访里大笑。我得了解这个场景的一切。奥斯卡怎么能忍住不笑的？史蒂夫真的是在笑吗？这是即兴发挥吗？好吧，我去查了剧本。
That talking head with Michael is completely scripted and Steve is just laughing so hard. He's laughing like how Steve laughs too when Steve thinks things are really funny. It's so good. No one is better at fake laughing than Steve Carell. He is the best. I got to tell you about my dad. So my dad is very, very foundational in my comedy writing career. Like, my biggest break was writing a Seinfeld episode and it was all basically the story
迈克尔的那段事后采访完全是按剧本演的，而史蒂夫只是笑得太厉害了。他笑的样子，就跟史蒂夫觉得事情真的很好笑时那种标志性的笑声一模一样。太棒了。没有人比史蒂夫·卡瑞尔更擅长假笑了。他绝对是最棒的。我得跟你讲讲我爸爸的事。我爸爸对我的喜剧编剧生涯有着非常非常深远的影响。比如说，我最大的突破就是写了一集《宋飛正傳》，那基本全都是根据我爸爸在纽约试图停车时发生的事情改编的。
of something that happened to my dad in New York where he was trying to park his car. He pulled the parking space episode where he pulls it, he backs into a space and something fronts into it. And someone's playing. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, that happened to my dad and he was so stubborn because he'd been trying to find a parking space for like 45 minutes and he just sat in his car and the other guy wouldn't budge either.
他拍了那个找停车位的剧集，当时他正准备倒车进一个车位，结果突然有人抢先进去了。还有人在那儿——哦，我不知道这件事。对，这事发生在我爸爸身上，他当时超级固执，因为他已经找了差不多45分钟的停车位，他就坐在车里不走，另一个人也赖着不肯挪窝。
And then my dad saw a friend of his walking down the street and he shouted out to him, get my wife, get her, bring me dinner. And, you know, it was like this really funny sort of New York conflict. Anyway, so I wrote that up and there's a lot of little references to my dad over the series. So for instance, in I guess the first dundies when Michael puts on a Karnak turban and does a joke about health care, who has better health care, yellow or, you know, that was a joke I wrote for my dad's comedy routine that he used to do in his company. He used to put on his turban and do do Karnak routine like Johnny Carson.
然后我爸爸看到他的一个朋友正沿着街走，就大声冲他喊：“去把我老婆叫来，把她叫来，给我带晚饭！”你知道的，这就像那种非常搞笑的纽约式冲突。总之，我就把这个写了进去，剧集里其实有很多向我爸爸致敬的小细节。比如说，我猜是在第一届邓迪奖上，迈克尔戴上卡纳克（Karnak）头巾，开了一个关于医疗保健的玩笑：谁有更好的医疗保健，黄色还是——你知道的，那个笑话是我为我爸爸以前在公司喜剧表演时写的。他以前会戴上头巾，像约翰尼·卡森（Johnny Carson）那样表演卡纳克节目。
Yeah, he would do Johnny Carson thing and he had a sidekick and I would write for him and he used to do this every year at the management meeting of his company. How old were you when you first wrote like a bit for him 14 or something? And so I used, but that was the exact joke. The one that's in the dundies was the exact joke that I used for my first joke for my dad that went over really well in his company. And there's other things in here. For instance, in the company, my dad was a salesman in this company at one point and
对，他会模仿约翰尼·卡森的节目，他还有一个黄金搭档，我以前会为他写稿。他每年都会在公司的管理层会议上表演这个。你第一次给他写段子时几岁？14岁左右吧？所以我就用了，但那就是原封不动的笑话。邓迪奖上那个笑话，就是我给我爸爸写的第一个笑话，在他的公司里反响特别好。这里面还有其他东西。比如说，在公司里，我爸爸曾经是这家公司的销售员，
he had a friend and they used to go on sales calls and they would, and the friend would pretend he had a metal plate in his head. So I put that in in the sales call. When D'Angelo was like trying to figure out what their bit is. And they would sort of double team these guys and, you know, try and get sympathy for the guy with the metal plate and yeah, so there's a lot in there. But one of the things that my dad does that to me is the most likable thing that he does is he gets on these runs where he's making himself crack up and his voice gets really
他有个朋友，他们以前一起去拜访客户推销，那个朋友会假装自己脑子里有块金属板。于是我就把这个情节写进了销售拜访中——当德安吉洛（D'Angelo）试图弄清楚他们的招牌把戏是什么的时候。他们会双管齐下对付那些客户，你知道的，试着博取人们对那个脑子里有金属板的家伙的同情。所以这里面有很多真实的影子。但其中有一件事，在我看来是我爸身上最讨人喜欢的特质，就是他会突然进入一种状态，把自己逗得哈哈大笑，声音变得非常尖，
high and he can barely speak through the laughter, you know what I mean? And Steve's always on some level reminded me of my dad. So this was like a total moment of overlap for me is seeing this thing that, you know, my dad would do coming out of Steve so brilliantly who, you know, knew my dad. I know that's some in-depth backstory for your friend and the coolest thing to me about this moment with Oscar is Oscar is always so superior to Steve. Like the essence of their relationship is Oscar's always right and he's always much more mature.
笑得几乎都说不出话来了，你知道我的意思吗？而史蒂夫在某种程度上总是让我想起我爸爸。所以对我来说，看到我爸会做的那种举动从史蒂夫身上完美地展现出来，而史蒂夫其实是认识我爸的，这真是一个绝妙的重合瞬间。我知道这对于你朋友和奥斯卡来说是一段很深入的背景故事，而对我来说，关于奥斯卡这个时刻最酷的事情是，奥斯卡在史蒂夫面前总是显得那么高高在上。他们关系的核心就是，奥斯卡总是对的，而且他总是成熟得多。
Actually. Michael. Yeah. And he corrects. He's like brava, you know, he's a little irritatingly correcting here and in this instance, Michael was smarter than Oscar Martinez to be between Steve and Oscar Nunez. I don't know. We have to have some kind of a contest.
实际上。迈克尔。是的。而且他会纠正别人。他会说“太棒了”（brava），你知道的，他在这儿总是有点烦人地纠正别人，但在这种情况下，迈克尔却比奥斯卡·马丁内斯（Oscar Martinez）更聪明——这究竟是指史蒂夫还是奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）呢？我不知道。我们得搞个什么比赛才行。
Yeah. I loved it. I loved it so much and it just anytime I hear stories like that were something that you write or any of our writers write and how it relates back to their life is just my favorite thing to hear. It's like our onset stories, like you guys have all the cool onset stories about, you know, the time that the heater fell over and started a fire and, you know, whatever it is, you don't have any of those cool stories, so it all has to be like, where'd you come
是的。我太喜欢了。我真的太喜欢了，每当我听到这样的故事——你写的或者我们任何编剧写的内容，以及它们是如何与他们的生活产生联系的——这绝对是我最爱听的事。这就好比我们在片场的各种故事，比如你们所有人都有一堆超酷的片场故事，关于那个加热器倒下来引发了一场火灾什么的，不管是什么故事，我却没有任何那种超酷的故事，所以一切都得变成：你到底是怎么想出这个点子的？
up with that? I love it. Well, now Michael is going to approach Angela Martin and I talked about this a little bit earlier. If you go to nine minutes and 51 seconds, you can see that my eyes are bright red, like they're all red. Angela, Paul Fieg said he had to call for makeup to give you eye drops to take the red out because you wouldn't stop crying and your eyes were so red.
我太喜欢了。好了，现在迈克尔要去找安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）了，我刚才稍微提过一点。如果你快进到9分51秒，你会看到我的眼睛红得发亮，全都是红血丝。安吉拉，保罗·费格（Paul Feig）说他不得不叫化妆师来给你滴眼药水，好把红血丝消掉，因为你一直在哭，眼睛红得厉害。
I know. Well, during the scene, you're going to show the pictures of your time with the senator and his super hot aide, Thomas. Is this the first part? Is this the first hint that we have of the aide and the senator or is that earlier? I feel like you had one comment about his aide earlier. Yes. No, why?
我知道。好吧，在这一幕里，你会展示那些你和参议员以及他超级性感的助手托马斯（Thomas）在一起的照片。这是第一次吗？这是我们第一次看到关于助手和参议员的线索，还是说之前就有了？我觉得你之前对他的助手有过一次评论。对。不对，为什么？
Didn't he join you for Valentine's Day or something? Yes. Yes. I've been in deleted scenes, but I shared it that everyone talks about how they're going to spend their Valentine's Day and Angela has a talking head where she was like, the senator's taking me out somewhere, but then he has to leave early to meet his aide, Thomas. They do a lot of late night work sessions. Yes.
他不是陪你过情人节什么的吗？对。对。这在删减片段里出现过，但我分享过，当时每个人都在谈论他们打算怎么过情人节，而安吉拉有一段事后采访，里面说：“参议员要带我去某个地方，但他得提前离开去见他的助手托马斯。”他们经常进行深夜工作会议。对。
Well, Randy shared with us that these pictures were not shot on a green screen. You actually went to an antique shop and you went to a nearby street to go rollerblading to shoot those photos. Do you remember that, Angela? I do. We were all in one day and we drove to a few different places and I was most excited about rollerblading because I love to roller skate and so I was very excited that my character got to do anything other than just sit in a corner and scowl.
好吧，兰迪（Randy）跟我们分享说，这些照片并不是在绿幕前拍摄的。你们实际上是去了一家古董店，还去了附近的一条街道去溜旱冰，为了拍那些照片。安吉拉，你还记得吗？我记得。我们把所有拍摄压缩在了一天内，去了几个不同的地方。我对溜旱冰最兴奋，因为我特别喜欢滑旱冰，所以我非常高兴我的角色终于能做点别的，而不只是坐在角落里愁眉苦脸了。
But rollerblading is very different than roller skating. It is. Can you do both? I can do both. I prefer roller skating. Right. But I was just excited to be outside and skate and I got to wear shorts and I got a day where I got to like travel around the valley.
但溜旱冰（rollerblading）和滑旱冰（roller skating）可大不一样。确实。你这两样都会吗？这两样我都会。我更喜欢滑旱冰。没错。但我当时只是很高兴能去户外滑冰，我还可以穿短裤，而且有一天我可以四处溜达，逛逛山谷。
Antiquing and rollerblading. Antiquing and rollerblading. It was really fun. Nice. So we have failed to mention D'Angelo's struggle in this episode, which is that, you know, he is being very tempted by all the snacks and the vending machine. We're going to see him in the break room now and he is making a s'more on the heating pad of the coffee maker and Andy is going to come in and say he needs some help with
淘古董和溜旱冰。淘古董和溜旱冰。真的超级好玩。太棒了。对了，我们还没来得及提到德安吉洛在这集里的挣扎，那就是，你知道的，他被各种零食和自动售货机诱惑得不行。我们现在将在休息室看到他，他正在咖啡机的加热垫上做一个棉花糖夹心饼干（s'more），然后安迪走进来，说他需要有人帮忙处理
a client. Greg, have you done this? Have you made a s'more like in a microwave or something? I feel like this is something you would do because I have been in the kitchen with you where you're like, we only had a few ingredients of something and maybe we didn't have all the right utensils. You're like, let's try it. Well, I went to boarding school.
一个客户。格雷格，你做过这个吗？你有没有在微波炉或者什么地方做过棉花糖夹心饼干？我觉得这是你会做的事，因为我和你在厨房待过，当时你说：“我们只有几种做某种东西的原料，可能还没有所有正确的餐具。”你会说：“我们试试看吧。”好吧，我上过寄宿学校。
So a lot of times, you know, if you, you couldn't cook, you had no access to the kitchen. And so sometimes you have to like make up stuff that you could do with one of those little coils that heats up and, you know, so if there was any grilled cheese with an iron sort of thing. Yeah, that kind of thing. So we had a fan catch from Madison M. and Denver, Colorado in this episode and I'm going to just say ahead of time, Madison is correct. Madison said, I noticed a continuity error in this episode at 10 minutes and 40 seconds.
所以很多时候，你知道的，如果你不能做饭，又没有厨房的使用权。有时候你不得不自己发明一些东西，用那种可以发热的小电热圈来做，你知道的，就像用熨斗做烤奶酪那种感觉。对，就是那种。所以我们在这一集里收到了来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的麦迪逊·M（Madison M.）的粉丝抓包，我先提前说一句，麦迪逊是对的。麦迪逊说：“我注意到这一集在10分40秒时有一个穿帮错误。
DeAngelo is cooking the marshmallow chocolate treat with the coffee pot and he walks in and at 10 minutes and 51 seconds, he throws it in the garbage with his left hand. But at 11 minutes, when he slaps the top of the doorway and leaves finger prints, it's with his right hand. That's a good catch. Yeah. I mean, it's possible he had chocolate all over himself, but that's a good catch. I remember that chocolate fingerprint hand being up there for a very long time.
德安吉洛正用咖啡壶烤棉花糖巧克力点心，他走了进来，然后在10分51秒时，他用左手把它扔进了垃圾桶。但在11分钟时，当他拍打门框顶部留下指纹时，用的却是右手。”这是一个很好的抓包。对。我是说，他身上沾满巧克力是有可能的，但这确实是个好抓包。我记得那个巧克力指纹在门框上留了很长一段时间。
I'm eager now to watch it and try to spot it every time. When was it ever cleaned off? I don't know if it ever was. I mean, it might be there till the end. I don't know, but I feel like it's definitely above my head when I'm doing the fake juggling in the break room in DeAngelo's last episode. Can I tell a quick story about The Simpsons? Yes.
我现在迫不及待地想去看一眼，每次都试着找找它。它到底有没有被清理干净过？我不知道它有没有被清理过。我是说，它可能会一直在那儿直到剧集结束。我不知道，但我感觉当我最后在休息室里表演假杂耍时，它绝对就在我头顶上方——那是德安吉洛的最后一集。我能讲一个关于《辛普森一家》的短故事吗？可以。
Yes, please. No, nobody wants stories about The Simpsons. When I joined the writing staff on The Simpsons, which was the end of season four, they were in the writer's room. There was this weird brown object stuck to the ceiling and it turned out that somebody had chewed up a bunch of carmels, stuck it on a doll of Bart on his spiky hair, and stuck him to the ceiling. That was like a little room bit for a while, and then the doll fell off and the carmels
好的，请讲。不，其实没人想听关于《辛普森一家》的故事。当我加入《辛普森一家》的编剧团队时，那已经是第四季末了，他们当时正在编剧室里。天花板上粘着一个奇怪的棕色物体，结果发现是有人嚼了一堆焦糖，把它粘在了一个巴特（Bart）的刺头娃娃上，然后把娃娃粘在了天花板上。那在房间里算是一个恶作剧梗，持续了一段时间，后来娃娃掉了下来，但焦糖
were there. This was like two years old by the time I got there, and they were like, oh, yes, I'll tell you the story about the carmels in the ceiling. It's just hardened. I was like, yeah, why does anybody clean it up? Those kind of things will last sometimes in an office, like the chocolate fingerprints could be there two years later. People are like, oh, yeah, that was a time that it just lives there now.
依然留在那里。等我到那儿的时候，这东西大概已经有两岁了，他们就说：“哦，对了，我得跟你讲讲天花板上那些焦糖的故事。”它都已经变硬了。我说：“好吧，为什么一直没人把它清理掉？”这种东西有时在办公室里能存留很久，就像那些巧克力指纹可能两年后还在。大家会说：“哦，对，那是某次留下的，现在它就永远在那儿了。”
I feel like I have those things in my house. I feel like I'm like, oh, yeah, that was a kid's- You become blind to the stuff in your house. I hope you don't. No, I mean, I feel like we have like, here's a perfect example. One year for Halloween, we put like hand prints and footprints on the gate, the side gate of our house. Okay.
我觉得我家里也有这种东西。我觉得我会说：“哦，对，那是某个孩子——”你对家里的一些东西会变得视而不见。我希望你不会。不，我是说，我觉得我们家也有，这里有个完美的例子。有一年万圣节，我们在大门上，也就是我们家的侧门上，印了一些手印和脚印。好吧。
They were like a path, like a scary path. When we peeled them off, part of them remained. They didn't peel off exactly and like part of the stickies there. Oh, I see. And now they just live there. Yeah. You get completely blind to the stuff in your environment. Like I'm sure that somewhere in my house, there's a list of things that a dog who died
它们就像是一条路，一条可怕的路。当我们把它们撕下来时，一部分还留着。它们没有完全撕干净，一部分黏胶还粘在那儿。哦，我明白了。现在它们就永远留在那儿了。对。你对周围环境里的这些东西会完全视而不见。就像我确信在我家里的某个地方，还贴着一张纸，上面写着一只大约六年前去世的狗狗不能吃什么东西之类的，它现在还贴在厨房里。被胶带粘着呢。别喂这只已经不在我们身边狗狗吃东西。不准吃鸡肉。你能做的最糟糕的事，就是拿出一块神奇海绵（magic eraser），开始擦掉墙上的一些手印，因为那样一来，你看到的只有你的墙有多么斑驳。对。这就是有孩子的日常生活。
like six years ago can't eat or whatever, it's just still in the kitchen. It's taped up. Do not feed this dog who no longer is with us. No chicken. The worst thing you can do is get out a magic eraser and start like erasering part of some hand prints on your wall because then all you see is like how smudgy your walls are. Yeah. That's life with kids.
这就是有孩子的日常生活。
Yeah. That's a hole I went down recently. Well, Oscar is going to ask Michael where he should send his last paycheck and everything hits Michael. He doesn't even know his address. It's real. Yeah. He said, I don't know.
好吧，奥斯卡要问迈克尔他的最后一笔薪水应该寄到哪里，这时候所有情绪一下子涌上了迈克尔的心头。他甚至连自己的地址都不知道。这是真的。对。他说：“我不知道，我住在山城（Mountain Tun）。”你知道的，他开始抓狂，然后他走进休息室，大家都在那儿闲晃，吃东西，过着普通的一天，而他坐在角落里，情绪变得越来越激动。
I live in Mountain Tun, you know, and he starts to freak out and then he goes into the break room and everyone is just hanging out and just eating and having a normal day and he's sitting in the corner and he's just becoming more and more emotional. Yeah. Pam's talking about how she's going to have to buy a new shredder because the last one broke. I love it that Kevin's like buy one that shreds magazines. Yeah.
对。帕姆正在谈论她不得不买一台新的碎纸机，因为上一台坏了。我太喜欢凯文说的话了，他说“买一台能碎杂志的”。对。他为什么对碎杂志这么执着？我不知道。很明显碎纸机就是他弄坏的。我知道。帕姆说：“凯文，没有一台碎纸机能碎杂志。”然后吉姆说：“凯文，该不会是你弄坏了上一台碎纸机吧？”我觉得这些都是非常真实的、像“墙角苍蝇”般窥探到的办公室对话。我太喜欢了。
Why is he so fixated on shredding magazines? I don't know. He clearly broke the shredder. I know. She's like, Kevin, none of them shred magazines and then Jim is like, Kevin, did you break the last shredder? These are such like real fly on the wall office conversations, I feel like. I love them.
好吧，这也是我非常喜欢这一集的地方，他就要离开了，有太多机会让那些极其平凡的时刻直击他的情感，比如最后当他回头看时，只有办公室即将下班的典型声音，而他是唯一一个知道自己要离开的人。但这又是那种让他无意中听到这些闲聊的时刻，然而这也为帕姆随后用来离开办公室的谎言做好了铺垫。对。对。
Well, that's what I'd love to also about this episode is he's leaving and there's so much opportunity for really mundane moments to hit him emotionally, like the very, very end when he looks back and it's just, you know, the typical sounds of the office is about to leave and he's the only one who knows he's leaving. But this is another one of those moments where he's just overhearing this chitter chatter and yet it's also setting up Pam's lie that's going to get her out of the office later. Yeah. Yeah.
但当你不得不对一个对你意义重大的人或事说再见时，这种感觉真的是太真实了。我甚至还记得，你知道的，当我们写书的时候，我回去重新看了大结局，那种重新经历最后一周的感觉，一切都被放大了。我想：“这是最后一份热点心。”是的。最后一次在10点半吃热狗。这是最后一次在这个片场冻得瑟瑟发抖。你还记得史蒂夫离开时我给他做的礼物吗？
But it's so true when you have to say goodbye to something that means a lot to you. I even remember, you know, when we were writing our book and I went back and I rewatched the finale and kind of reliving that last week and everything became big. I'm like, this is the last hot snack. Yeah. Last time I'm going to have, you know, hot dogs at 1030. This is the last time I'm going to be freezing on this set. Do you remember the gift that I made for Steve when he left?
基本上，我去了三个他经常工作的地方，拍了非常高清的照片，拍下他平时会看到的景象。他的视野。也就是他对剧组工作人员和其他演员的视野。所以我有一张他坐在办公桌后方的第一视角照片，我把所有的——你知道的，我把瓦达（Vada）坐在那儿拿着笔记本、还有摄像机都拍进去了，你知道的，这样当他从拍摄中抬起头时，能有一个提醒，让他想起自己以前看到的是什么。然后我又做了一张你们所有人在会议室里的照片，那是他站在会议室前面时看到的情景。
So basically I went and I saw three places that he did a lot of work from and I took very high quality photos of what he would see. His view. So his view of the crew and the other cast. So I had one from him behind his desk in his POV and I put like all the, you know, I put Vada sitting there with her notebook and the cameras and, you know, so that it was like a reminder of what he used to see when he looked up from his filming and then I did one of all you guys in the conference room, what he saw when he was standing in front
我想在大房间里还有另一张，里面有很多剧组工作人员。对。这样他就能记住他对这些事物的视角是什么样的，但这在情感上其实和这里的效果有点异曲同工。这就好像他坐在这里，只是看着一个普通的场景。
of the conference room. And I think there was one other one in the bigger room that had all a lot of the crew in it. Yeah. Just so he could remember what his point of view was of those things, but it's sort of the same thing a little bit emotionally here. It's like here he is sitting and he's just looking out at, you know, an average scene from that.
对。工作中的场景。而正是这些时刻最直击心灵。好了，现在他要走进办公室，然后他说：“我做不到，我做不到。”他开始为搬家的事情感到抓狂，在离开之前，他给霍莉打了电话。他在这一集里有我最喜欢的一句台词，那就是：“我不会从第一表演级别开始上的。
Yeah. Job. And those are the ones that hit you so hard. Well, he's going to go into his office now and he's like, I can't do this. I can't do this. And he's starting to freak out about moving and he's going to call Holly before he does. He has my favorite line in the episode, which is, I'm not going to start in profit level one.
我觉得我的学分大概不能转过去。”如果你上过即兴表演课，你们就会知道，里面有超级多的级别，如果你由于某种原因不得不重复上某个级别，有时候会有大约八个级别。这句话真的戳中我了。我用过好多次了。所以我觉得史蒂夫最牛的地方，在于他能够同时在脑子里处理多重情绪的能力。我太喜欢这段台词了。
I don't think my credits are going to transfer. If you've taken improv class, you guys, there are so many levels and if you have to repeat a level for whatever reason, there's like eight levels sometimes. And that just got me. I've said it a many times. So the thing I think is so brilliant about Steve is his ability to play multiple things going on in his head at the same time. And I love the speech.
太搞笑了。这段台词里的每件事都非常好笑。他竟然在担心自己的即兴表演学分，这实在是太出乎意料了。我们觉得他有好几年都没去上过即兴表演课了吧，你知道的，我喜欢想象他其实一直在上。对。对。对我来说，这就像是一集“精选集”。
It's so funny. Everything is really funny in the speech. It's just so unexpected that he's worrying about his improv credits. I don't think we've thought about him being an improv class in years, you know, I love to think that he's been in it all along. Yeah. Yeah. This is like a greatest hits episode to me.
这就好像是，你知道的，这也是为什么我能写这一集感到如此高兴的原因，因为我对这里之前的每一集都有记忆，从试播集到这一集，和他在一起的回忆，还做了一些小小的致意。就像那是多么出色的一集由詹（Gens）大量执笔的剧集，也就是他在里面做即兴表演并创造出迈克尔·斯卡恩（Michael Scarn）的那集。所以那是我们对那集的致意。对。这里有很多对之前整部剧历史的致意，我觉得在很多
It's like, this is, you know, that was one of the reasons why I was so happy to be able to write it because I have memories of every episode going up to here with him from the pilot to this episode and making little references to it. Like that was such a brilliant gents a lot of written episode, the one where he's doing improv and he invents Michael Skarn and yeah. So that's our little reference to that. Yeah. There's the references to like the whole history up to this point, I think, and a lot
这样的小场景里都有体现。兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）给我发了这一集的通告单（call sheets），我得以看到了史蒂夫最后一天拍摄日的通告单。休息室里的那一幕，那是第一场要拍的。我们早上7点钟拍的。那是他最后一天拍摄的场景之一。然后就是这一幕，他在里面抓狂并给霍莉打电话，这也是在他最后一天拍的。
of these little scenes. Randy Cordray sent me the call sheets for this episode and I was able to look at the call sheet for Steve's final shooting day. That scene in the break room, that was first up. We shot that at 7 a.m. That was one of the scenes on his last day. And then this scene where he's freaking out and he calls Holly, this was also on his last day.
你提到保罗·费格几乎把他这一天的时间都排满了最具伤感、最情绪化的时刻。他一整天都在哭。基本上是这样的。对。好吧，我是说，等到拍吉姆和迈克尔的那场戏时，那是剪辑起来最艰难的一场。我是说，他们在那个场景里都彻底崩溃了。
You mentioned that Paul Feig sort of stacked his day with the most sentimental, most emotional moments. He had to cry all day. Basically, yeah. Yeah. Well, he was, I mean, by the time it got to the Jim Michael scene, that was the biggest difficult one to edit. I mean, they were both just complete messes in that scene.
对。我是说，我一直跑去找保罗·费格说：“想想办法让他们别哭了。”对。太多了。好吧，当史蒂夫用迈克尔的声音说话时，你知道的，当他说“你来的时候还是个年轻人”时，他的声音都颤抖了，我当时简直——我简直要哭了。接下来是我最喜欢的场景之一，因为迈克尔不得不和托比告别，
Yeah. I mean, I kept running into Paul Feig saying, tell them to dry it up somehow. Yeah. It's too much. Well, when Steve is Michael's voice, you know, it cracks when he goes, you came here as a young man. I was like, I was like crying. Coming up is one of my favorite scenes because Michael is going to have to say goodbye to
他必须竭尽全力不向托比说出什么糟糕的话。他做到了。甚至当托比告诉他在科罗拉多州有个兄弟时，他也忍住了。我是说，迈克尔简直无法摆脱这一大家子沉闷无趣的人，当他说“什么？”时，你知道的，就像那个GIF动图里他不停地喊“不，不”，你知道的，那是他脑子里正在发生的心理活动。但他做到了。然后凯利只是希望他赶紧走开。
Toby and he has to do his best to not say something awful to Toby. And he does it. It is amazing even when Toby tells him that he has a brother in Colorado. I mean, Michael cannot get away from this family of wet blankets when he's like, what? And you know, like that GIF that him just going, no, no, like, you know, that's what is going on inside of his head. But he does it. And then Kelly just wants him to walk away.
对。但接着我想，当他把圣保利女郎（St. Pauli Girl）霓虹灯牌送给瑞安，而且他整个衣柜都是蓝色的时，这又是另一首“精选集”吗？对。很有趣。和菲利斯以及她的烤箱手套擦肩而过的那个情节我们没提到，但那是对第一集圣诞节的致意。是的。
Yeah. But then I guess, is this another greatest hits when he gives Ryan his St. Pauli girl neon sign and his whole closet is blue. Yeah. It's funny. The one with, we didn't mention going by with Phyllis and her, and her mitten, but that's a reference to the first Christmas episode. Yes.
而且他以前恨极了她为他做的那个蠢透了的烤箱手套。我喜欢她在这里真的在考验他的成熟度，因为她对这个手套的描述以及你应该如何清洗它的方式，简直是最糟糕的礼物。她说：“你不能洗它，必须风干，它就像所有这些——你不能把它弄湿。你不能把它弄湿。”就像所有这些要求。
And he hated that stupid oven mitt that she made for him. And I love that she's, she's really testing his maturity here because the description that she has of this mitten and how you're supposed to clean it, it's like the worst gift. And she's like, you can't wash it, it has to be air-dried, it's like all these, you can't get it wet. You can't get it wet. Like all these things.
对。这简直是一个糟糕透顶、毫无用处的手套，但他对她却那么好。但你可以——你完全知道他心里想说什么。对。对。所以有几个非常棒的删减片段，格雷格。它们在DVD上，我想向你问起其中一个。当迈克尔在休息室里经历这个情绪崩溃的时刻时，有点——
Yeah. It's just, it's just horrible useless mitten and he's so nice to her. But you can, you know exactly what he wants to say. Yeah. Yeah. So there are a few really great deleted scenes, Greg. They're on the DVD and I wanted to ask you about one of them. When Michael is having this moment in the break room where he's getting emotional, kind
我在这里稍微回放一下。有一个被剪掉的节拍没有在播出的剧集中出现，他脱下靴子，把它们扔进了垃圾桶。他在屋顶上穿的那双靴子，就像是在说：“靴子，我要去科罗拉多啦。”最后克里夫（Creed）竟然穿上了它们。他在垃圾桶里找到了它们。对。但这其中有你个人的亲身经历吗？
of, I'm toggling back here for a second. There is this beat that didn't make it to the air episode where he takes off his boots and throws them in the trash. Those boots that he had on the roof is like, boots, I'm going to Colorado. And then ultimately Creed ends up wearing them. He finds them in the trash. Yeah. But was that from a personal story for you?
对，那是一个个人的亲身经历。我其实觉得在我的第一版剧本草稿中，靴子的戏份更重要，因为我觉得你在屋顶上几乎看不到它们。我注意到了。哦，对。非常清楚。我当时很震惊迈克尔竟然穿了牛仔靴。一个学生带来的。
Yeah, that was a personal story. I kind of think that the boots were a bigger deal in my first draft of the script because I think you barely see them on the rooftop. I noticed them. Oh, right away. Very clearly. I was shocked that Michael was wearing cowboy boots. A student brings.
不过我并没有深入研究过牛仔靴。对。但那事确实发生在我身上。我去参观了德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，在那里深受启发，买了一双牛仔靴，因为每个人都有牛仔靴，我把它带了回来，还在纽约穿着它。我决定穿着这双牛仔靴从我的公寓走到我在《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）的工作地点。
I did not deep dive cowboy boots though. Yeah. But that happened to me. I went to visit Austin, Texas and I got very inspired to buy a pair of cowboy boots while I was there because everybody had cowboy boots and I brought them back and was wearing them in New York. I decided I was walking from my apartment to my job at Saturday Night Live wearing these cowboy boots.
那得走多远啊？对，大概有两英里远，踩在纽约的水泥地上，穿着牛仔靴。等我走到那儿的时候，我就想：“你知道的，我有扁平足，我真的不该穿牛仔靴。”不管怎样，脚痛得要命，我把它们脱下来扔了，换了一双运动鞋。而A·惠特尼·布朗（A. Whitney Brown），他是《周六夜现场》的一位编剧，有着更加地道的乡村背景。
How big of a walk was that? Yeah, it was like two miles on the concrete of New York in the cowboy boots. By the time I got there, I was like, you know, I've got like flat feet and this really should not be wearing cowboy boots. And anyway, they were so painful that I took them off and threw them out and got a pair of sneakers. And A. Whitney Brown, who was this writer on Saturday Night Live who had a much more authentic country background.
他的墙上挂着他祖母的松鼠食谱或者类似的东西。而且他大概没有扁平足。对，可能没有。他把靴子捞了回来，我发誓，在我呆在那档节目的余下时间里，他几乎天天穿着它们。他就是你的克里夫。对，他就是克里夫。
He had his grandmother's recipe for vitals, which is like a squirrel or something on his wall. And maybe not flat feet. Yeah, probably not. He fished them out and I swear he wore them every day for the rest of the time that I was on that show. He was your creed. Yeah, he was the creed.
所以无论如何，我稍微借用了这个笑话，但它被删减了，因为它对我来说可能比对任何人都更有意义。但我确实觉得这个情节挺不错的，因为克里夫——我记不清那个场景的笑点是什么了，但我感觉克里夫说了类似“你觉得真的是因为靴子吗？”然后他们说：“不，我们觉得是因为别的情绪。”他说：“太好了。”然后他把靴子抓走了。对。
So anyway, I cribbed that joke a little bit, but it was a deleted scene because it was probably more meaningful to me than anybody else. But I do think it was good because creed, I can't remember what the bloat of that scene was, but I feel like creed says something like you think it really was the boots and then they're like, no, we don't think we think it was something emotional. He's like, good. He grabs the boots out. Yeah.
就像是——穿点什么吧。你得确保拿走靴子没问题。对。他只是在乎——哦，迈克尔扔靴子的时候是不是有点眼泪汪汪的？对。我是说，他说他的脚疼什么的。这就是他扔靴子的原因。
Like wear something. You want to make sure it was okay to take the boots. Yeah. He's just carried about. Oh, is Michael like kind of teary when he throws the boots away? Yeah. I mean, he says that his feet hurt or something. That's why he throws the boots.
对。而且这双靴子本来也应该是——我没看过删减片段。所以我不知道里面发生了什么。这双靴子本应象征着他搬去科罗拉多，而此时他正在质疑自己到底要不要去科罗拉多。所以他把靴子给扔了。好吧。
Yeah. And the boots are also supposed to be. I didn't see the deleted scene. So I didn't know what happens in it. The boots are supposed to be sort of symbolic of his move to Colorado and at this point he's questioning if he's going to go to Colorado. So he gets rid of his boots. Okay.
没错。所以现在我们来到了会议室。派对策划委员会还在策划这场派对。他们动作太慢了。梅雷迪思想要一个色情蛋糕。她说这真的很棒，因为蛋糕上面描绘的都是真实的女性。对。然后菲利斯说：“作为经常买色情蛋糕的人，能被代表感觉真好。”对。我太喜欢这个场景了。我觉得这不在我的编剧初稿里。我觉得这个是B·J（BJ）写的。我觉得这是在编剧室里集体创作的场景。不过真的非常搞笑。
Right. So now we're in the conference room. The party planning committee is still planning this party. They're so slow. Meredith would like to get an erotic cake. And she said they're really great because they have real women depicted on the cakes. Yeah. And Phyllis is like, as someone who buys a lot of erotic cakes, it just feels good to
你说是额外加的场景，这挺有意思的。我想当你们获得批准把这一集加长（supersize）时，我们收到这个消息有点晚了，所以我们确实拍了一些不涉及史蒂夫的镜头。因为他已经走了，所以拍不了。我们是一周后拍的。这就是其中之一。我确实抓到一个14分51秒的穿帮。有人注意到安吉拉·马丁现在把头发放下来了吗？没有。
be represented. Yeah. I love this scene. I don't think this was in my writer's draft. I feel like it goes to BJ in here. I feel like this is a room written scene. It's very funny though. It's interesting you say that this was an extra scene.
整整一集里，她的头发都是用发夹盘在后面的。然后突然在这个额外的派对策划委员会场景里，她的头发是散开的。我注意到我的头发漂亮多了。不知怎么的，我们弄我头发的方式，结果比原本拍摄的那一周还要好看。所以很明显，这里有一些连续性的照片问题，因为有人没有注意到你的头发一直是盘起来的。而且我怎么就没注意到呢？我当时刚拍完这一集，当他们没给我夹发夹时，我甚至都没有意识到。
I guess when you guys got permission to supersize this episode, we got that news a little late and we did shoot a couple of things that did not involve Steve. They couldn't because he was gone. We shot this a week later. This was one of them. I do have a continuity catch at 14 minutes 51 seconds. Did anyone notice that Angela Martin now has her hair down? No.
你还记得这种事吗？你必须得记得，我想。有时候会记得，对。我是说，有很多次我会说：“哦，不，不，不，那一幕我编了辫子。”但不管出于什么原因，这一天我居然没发现。好吧，也许色情蛋糕的话题让你放松了下来。
The whole entire episode, she has her hair pulled back in a clip. And then all of a sudden in this extra party planning committee scene, her hair is down. I noticed that my hair is much prettier. Somehow the way we did my hair, it turned out prettier than the original week of shooting. So clearly there were some continuity photo issues because someone did not notice that your hair had been up. And why didn't I notice? I had just filmed this episode when they didn't put the clip in, I didn't even register
把头发放下来。把头发解开。把头发解开。对，没错。好吧，迈克尔要去找帕姆，但她正匆忙赶出去。对，我和史蒂夫在办公大楼开放区域（bullpen）的那场戏是在最后一天拍的。我们还没谈到的另一条故事线是，盖布（Gabe）一直在死缠烂打地试图追回艾琳。
it. Do you remember that kind of stuff? You got to, I guess. Sometimes, yeah. I mean, there are many times where I'd be like, oh no, no, no, I had my hair in a braid for that. But for whatever reason, I didn't catch it on this day. Well, maybe the topic of erotic cakes made you relax.
他一直去洗手间找她。他有点在跟安迪较劲，但在16分15秒时，我们迎来了一个对《女性赏识日》（Women's Appreciation）的超级棒的回应，因为克里夫从女洗手间出来了。那是他解决“大号”的地方。他之前已经说得很清楚了。他在那里面感觉更舒服。我不知道自从《女性赏识日》之后我们还有没有去过那个洗手间。
Take your hair down. Take your hair out. Take your hair out. Yeah, exactly. Well, Michael is going to approach Pam, but she's rushing out. Yeah, that was shot on the last day, that scene of me and the bullpen with Steve. The other storyline that's going on that we haven't talked about is that Gabe is really just kind of aggressively trying to get Erin back.
女洗手间？我不知道我们有没有去过。我是说，男洗手间。我们跟迈克尔一起去过男洗手间好多次了，但我觉得你是对的。我不确定我们是不是又回到了女洗手间。我太喜欢这一段刚开始时吉姆的台词了。就像是：“所以你们现在在洗手间里拍？你们现在连我们上厕所都要拍了？”
And he keeps going in the restroom to look for her. He's kind of getting aggressive with Andy, but at 16 minutes, 15 seconds, we have a great call back to women's appreciation because Creed is going to come out of the women's restroom. That's where he does his number twos. He's made that clear. He's much nicer in there. I don't know if we've been in the restroom since women's appreciation.
对。这一段拍得真的很好。扎克·伍兹（Zach Woods）在这场戏里简直绝了，他在里面威胁安迪。对我来说，他就是那种演员，无论他说什么我都觉得搞笑。我要是跟他拍对手戏，肯定会一直笑场。好吧，接下来，我们要通过视频通话见见托比的兄弟罗里（Rory）。托比要把迈克尔要去科罗拉多的事告诉罗里。罗里想知道迈克尔是否喜欢果酱，因为他可以送迈克尔一篮子果酱。
The women's? I don't know if we have. I mean, the men's. We've been in the men's quite a bit with Michael, but I think you're right. I'm not sure we've been back into the women's restroom. I love the gym line at the beginning of this. It's like, so you're filming in the restroom? You're filming us going to the bathroom now?
他有很多果酱。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州博尔德市（Boulder）的汉娜·L（Hannah L）的粉丝提问：“托比在科罗拉多州的兄弟是由保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）的亲兄弟沃伦（Warren）扮演的吗？如果是的话，这是怎么促成的？这是计划已久的吗？这是编剧墙上的一个梗吗？”现在，我记得沃伦和保罗讨论过这个，我也记得他们一直在斟酌托比的兄弟应该叫什么名字。
Yeah. That was really well done. Zach Woods is hilarious in this thing where he's just threatening Andy. He's the type of actor for me that anything he says is just hilarious to me. I would always laugh if I was in a scene with him. Well, coming up, we're going to meet Toby's brother, Rory, on a video call. Toby is going to let Rory know about Michael coming to Colorado. Rory would like to know if Michael likes jam because he could give him a basket of jam.
当时，我一直在翻看我当年演戏剧时的老照片。那里有个家伙。人挺好的，但有点把我们都逼疯了，他叫罗里。戏剧团里总会有一个这样的人，我就说：“罗里这个名字，你们一定要用罗里这个名字。把这个名字写到名单上去。”我一直很好奇，我不知道最后是谁投的票，但我确保罗里上了名单。对那个角色来说，罗里也是个很棒的名字。
He has lots of jams. We had a fan question from Hannah L in California. Is Toby's Colorado brother played by Paul Lieberstein's real brother, Warren? If so, how did this come about? Was it planned for a while? Was this a card on the writer's wall? Now, I remember Warren and Paul talking about this, and I remember them kicking around names for what Toby's brother's name would be.
这有点像《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）里的“乡村陪审员”（rural juror）。听起来就是那种非常无力、非常软绵绵的声音。很难发音。很难。很难发音。再加上弗林德森（Flindersen）。听起来就是罗里。罗里·弗林德森。
At the time, I had been going through old photos of my theater days. There was the sky. That was very nice, but kind of drove us all crazy named Rory. There's always one person in a theater group, and I was like, the name Rory, you've got to use the name Rory. Put that name on the list. I always wonder, I don't know who ended up voting, but I made sure Rory got on the list. Rory's a great name for that character, too.
你真的能从他们父母给儿子起名字的选择中感受到一些端倪，托比和罗里。罗里对果酱有着某种奇异的迷恋。你懂的，这绝对是可能衍生出的衍生剧之一。是的，没准。没错。与罗里一起做果酱。这就是迈克尔和罗里在科罗拉多。好吧，我为此联系了沃伦，他告诉我——我引用他的原话。
It's sort of like the rural juror on 30 Rocks. It's just a really weak, soft sort of sound. It's hard to say. It's hard. It's hard to say. Combined with Flindersen. It just sounds Rory. Rory Flindersen.
他说：“最后在我和史蒂夫·布西密（Steve Buscemi）之间挑选扮演托比的兄弟，但史蒂夫被认为长得太帅了。哈哈。”然后他说：“能参演这个小场景真的超级好玩。他们大概拍了六次。拍完第二条后，保罗·费格走过来对我说：‘演得很棒，但能不能请你再多嘟囔一点，就像托比那样？’然后拍完下一条后，又是同样的建议：‘能不能请你再多嘟囔点？’
You really get a sense of their parents and the name choice for their sons, Toby and Rory. Rory's got some kind of bizarre fascination with jams. You just, that's one of the possible spinoffs. Yes, exactly. Exactly. Jamming with Rory. It's Michael and Rory in Colorado. Well, I reached out to Warren about this, and he told me, I'm going to quote him.
所以接下来的那条，我真的放开了演，嘟囔得如此厉害，以至于我自己嘴里说出来的话都快听不清了。拍完那条后，我还道了歉，因为我可能觉得这太荒谬了，简直是一堆胡言乱语。而保罗·费格却说：‘不，这太完美了。如果你能试着再多嘟囔一点点，你知道的，就像托比那样。’沃伦说，我想直到那个时候，我才真正感激我的兄弟原来是个嘟囔天才。”我们收到了来自科罗拉多州博尔德市的内华达·D（Nevada D）的粉丝抓包，他说：“背景抓包。
He said, it came down between me and Steve Buscemi to play Toby's brother, but Steve was considered too handsome. Haha. And then he said, this little scene was a ton of fun to be in. They shot it maybe six times. And after the second take, Paul Fee came up and said, it's great, but could I please mumble a little bit more like Toby? Then after the next take, again, same note, could I please mumble more?
这个我憋了好久了，现在终于能分享出来，我太激动了。在这集里，我们看到托比正在和他的兄弟罗里进行视频聊天，罗里住在科罗拉多州的博尔德。透过罗里窗户看到的风景是科罗拉多州查托夸国家历史地标（Chautauqua National Historical Landmark）或者平铁山（Flat Irons）。根据这个视野，罗里·弗伦德森（Flunderson）住在博尔德的基线路（Baseline Road）上，这意味着他在镇那个地段住，应该相当富有。”好吧，兰迪·科德雷说，他打电话给他在科罗拉多州布鲁姆菲尔德（Broomfield）一位名叫托达·帕兹尔（Todd Pazzle）的好朋友，请托德去博尔德拍一张标志性的平铁山的照片。
So the next take, I really went for it and mumbled so hard that I could barely understand the words coming out of my own mouth. After that shot, I apologized because I thought it was ridiculous, probably, and just a bunch of gibberish. And Paul Fee said, no, it was perfect. And if I could try to mumble even a bit more, you know, like Toby and Warren said, I think it wasn't really until that point that I truly appreciated my brother was a mumbling genius. We had a fan catch from Nevada D in Boulder, Colorado, who said, background catch.
照片中看到的房子其实是公园里的护林员站。兰迪还说，托德和兰迪一起攀登过背景中看到的几处平铁山岩层。哇。当人们有机会成为角色时，这真的很有趣。我是说，很显然，在这一点上，罗里本来不会对这部剧产生巨大的影响，除非我们去科罗拉多看望迈克尔。但其中一些角色太随性了，因为托比这个角色最初只是保罗在读剧本围读时的台词，而凯文·赖利（Kevin Reilly）更多地展现了他自己，他很有趣。然而当我扮演住在迈克尔公寓隔壁的那个毛线销售员时，却根本没下文。好吧，没有高管的笔记。没有人说要更多毛线销售员。好吧，我被抓包了。
I've been holding onto this one for a while now, and I am so excited to share. In this episode, we see Toby video chatting with his brother, Rory, who lives in Boulder, Colorado. The view through Rory's window is of the Chautauqua National Historical Landmark or the Flat Irons. Based on this view, Rory Flunderson lives on Baseline Road in Boulder, and that would mean that he's rather wealthy for living in that part of town. Well, Randy Cordray said that he called a very good friend of his named Todd Pazzle
我甚至知道他从未出现过。没错。那是被删减的片段。好吧，那是你的失误。对，没错。所以迈克尔的告别仪式已经进行了一半左右。我想我们现在可以休息一下，下周再接着讲。我也这么觉得，不然这一集就要变成两小时长的巨长集了。
of Broomfield, Colorado, asked Todd to go to Boulder and shoot an image of the iconic Flat Irons. The house seen in the image is the actual ranger station at the park. And Randy said Todd and Randy have climbed several of the Flat Iron formations seen in the background. Wow. That's interesting when people get to be characters. I mean, obviously, at this point, Rory was not going to have a giant impact on the show
好的，伙计们，非常感谢你们发来提问。我们下周会回答剩下的问题。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）联合制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）担任执行制作人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。
probably unless we went to see Michael in Colorado. But some of them are so random because the Toby character was just Paul reading a line at the table, and Kevin Reilly being more of him, he's funny. And yet when I played the yarn salesman that lives next to Michael in the condo, it just didn't go anywhere. No, no notes from the execs. Nobody was like more yarn salesman. Well, I caught him.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kieffer），我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbico）。我们的主题曲是克里夫·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡皮树》（Rubber Tree）。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I even knew he never appeared. That's right. That was a deleted scene. Well, that was your mistake. Yeah, exactly. So Michael's about halfway through his goodbyes. I think we take a break now and we finish up next week. I think so too, because otherwise this would be like a two hour episode.
我甚至知道他根本没出现。没错。那是一段被删减的镜头。好吧，那是你的错。对，没错。迈克尔的告别差不多进行到了一半。我想我们现在休息一下，下周再完成剩下的部分。我也这么觉得，否则这就成了一集两小时的节目了。
Yes. All right, you guys, thank you so much for sending in your questions. We're going to get to the rest of them next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
是的。好了，各位，非常感谢你们发来问题。我们将在下周解答剩下的问题。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。